bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soit la première visite des
manuels macro à kiev on va y consacrent
une large partie de cette émission le
président français a clairement affiché
son soutien à paul dini regel end qui n
était pas seul entouré de ses homologues
italiens allemands et roumains l'europe
unie aux côtés de l'ukraine on va
revenir sur les mots sur les images de
cette visite importante et plus sur les
annonces concrètes bien sûr à une
semaine d'un conseil européen décisif
sur l'avenir de l'ukraine au sein des 27
une visite qui intervient en pleine
campagne des législatives en trois jours
du second tour ce qui ce site les vives
critiques des oppositions
arrière-pensées électorales suspicions
d' instrumentalisation mélange des
genres on fera le tour des réactions
dans la deuxième partie de cette
émission enfin ce seront les partis pris
de nos a franchi ce soir dans le carnet
de campagne dès l'amont d'un gab a jusqu
où ira nicolas sarkozy pour soutenir
emmanuel macron le mot de la semaine ses
harmonies répété sur tous les tons jean
luc mélenchon verra cela avec la
sémiologue mariette darrigrand et puis
l'international avec un sens du jeu qui
va revenir sur ces charters de la honte
de boris johnson dans la peau de menus
c'est parti
m
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs c'est l'image du jour
quatre chefs d'état et de gouvernement
le chancelier allemand olaf scholz le
président du conseil italien mario
draghi le président roumain klaus
iohannis ce et le président français
emmanuel macron tous vous le voyez aux
côtés de volodymyr zelensky qui
contrastait lui avec son t-shirt
militaire son t-shirt kaki on va prendre
le temps de s'arrêter ce soir sur les
images et sur cette visite importante
général trinquant bonsoir et merci
d'être là ancien chef de la mission
militaire française des nations unies on
a besoin de comprendre si les canons
caesar supplémentaires peuvent changer
ou ou non la donne sur le terrain
bonsoir ariane chemin bienvenue à
nouveau sur ce plateau est grand
reporter au monde et vous revenez
d'ukraine vous nous direz un peu ce
qu'on pense du président français sur
place vous avez signé un très long
papier très fouillé dans les rouages de
la machine zelensky c'est un véritable
système de résistance de à l'occupation
russe vous en parlerez vous avez
rencontré d'ailleurs ou pas au cours de
son numéro 2 sentir super alexis kohler
et puis j'ai rencontré sa femme ah bah
vous nous direz alors bon soir vincent
vincent hugeux journaliste spécialiste
des terrains de conflits chroniqueur
régulier dans cette émission la députée
ukrainienne franco-ukrainienne de la
majorité elle est là valérie forme
initiale est avec nous depuis sa
circonscription de la loire députée
sortante vous ne vous présentez pas mais
vous êtes vous êtes toujours député puis
richard verville à nous rejoindre dans
un instant visage familier de l'émission
il connaît bien les questions
européennes et il est correspondant
france europe pour le média suisse blick
alors qu'est ce qu'il faut en retenir de
cette visite on va voir ça avec vous
tout de suite stéphane si j'ai bien
compris c'est à lui tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir manque à wade'' bonsoir
à tous et à tous un des jeux si j'ai
bien compris ce soir si j'ai bien
compris myriam lundi dernier à orly
c'est le président français qui est
monté dans l'avion très un petit
discours sur le tarmac mais aujourd'hui
à kiev c'était le président français de
l'union européenne ça c'est différent
parce qu'en france fil des mois on est
un peu dans les vapeurs de la campagne
on a tendance à tout analysé par rapport
au second tour mon sens là il n'était
pas tout seul le président macron il y
avait quand même le premier ministre
italien le chancelier allemand le
premier ministre roumain donc on
reproche souvent à l'europe d'être
identité un peu vaporeuse bon là il y
avait quand même quelque chose de solide
man incarné à kiev en soutien à zell
inscrits et avant de rencontrer le
président ukrainien
ses dirigeants se sont arrêtés à irin
les ruines du recul exactement et repine
cindy quand on a beaucoup parlé au début
du conflit c'est là qu'est réseau curie
ont réussi à stopper l'avancé
des russes c'est la ville où poutine a
fait tirer sur les quartiers
résidentiels sur des immeubles donc le
président macron là il a pu voir de ses
yeux vraiment les conséquences ceux des
bombardements russie d'ailleurs parlé de
barbarie alors je sais pas si le fait
d'être confronté au théâtre de guerres
d'influencé mais jusqu'à présent il y
avait toujours une certaine distance
dans son analyse du conflit la veille
encore en roumanie il disait il ya deux
hypothèses il ya l'hypothèse de la
victoire aux crânienne et puis l'autre
hypothèse où il faudrait négocier avec
la russie
sans dire qu'il y aura des concessions
territoriales mais bon c'était un peu
sous-entendu alors aujourd'hui en
ukraine il n'y avait plus qu'une seule
hypothèse qui tiennent en écoute c'est
le premier message que je voulais
adresser aux côtés de mes homologues
l'europe est à vos côtés elle le restera
autant qu'il le faudra jusqu'à la
victoire qui aura le visage du retour de
la paix dans une ukraine libre et
indépendante alors les symboles c'est
très important au delà de ça il ya des
décisions qui ont été a montré qu'en
symbole qu'est ce qu'on ferait bas il ya
des décisions sur le pré la première
édition c'est d'accorder à l'ukraine
donc ce statut officiel de candidat à
l'entrée dans l'union européenne dont ça
ne veut pas dire je vous dis pas voir
rien de chemin mais ceux qui nous
regardent que l'ukraine va devenir cette
année le 28e pays de l'union en fait
c'est un statu quo n'accorde pas très
facilement je donne deux exemples la
turquie ils ont demandé à 87 ils ont eu
douze ans plus tard l'album il a demandé
en 2009 ils ont on a commencé à examiner
simplement leur candidature cinq ans
plus tard la l'ukraine ils ont demandé
qu'on examine leur dossier de
candidature le 28 février et 3 mois plus
tard ça y est la candidature est
acceptée il annonce est liée à l'
attaque de la russe mais scott pour dire
c'est un geste fort tu devrais être
validée la semaine prochaine à bruxelles
mais en tout cas les quatre leaders
europe inquiète et là ils étaient tous
d'accord pour le réclamer tous les
quatre nous soutenons le statut de
candidat immédiat à l'adhésion à l'union
européenne pour l'ukraine ce statut sera
assorti nous l'avons 10 tous ensemble
d'une feuille de route et impliquera
aussi que soit prise en compte la
situation des balkans occidentaux
et du voisinage en particulier de la
moldavie alors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire qu'il ya aussi
d'autres qu'ils se sont précipités pour
demander justement d'être acceptée comme
candidat et la moldavie et la géorgie
donc le prison matheron à leur dire on
va en parler mais on va dissocier les
deux si on comprend que voilà c'est pas
pour tout de suite même si on ils ont un
calendrier et que ce statut de candidat
est acceptée l'urgence ce sont les
livraisons d'armes annonce sur ce sujet
avec lui parce que c'est vrai que madame
à tron était venu au nom de l'union
européenne et vit un moment ben il a
parlé au nom de la france alors je sais
pas si vous êtes au courant mon général
vous le savez certainement que tu un
cavalier nous vous parlez d'artillerie
vous me lisez régulièrement parce qu'on
a un des meilleurs canons du monde
paraît-il pas le canon caesar autant
vous le montrer à l'escem une sacrée
bestioles et donc on en avait 76 je
crois en france et on à son autre nom
contingent donnait déjà 12 hélas le
président macron a annoncé airbus
auxquels j'ai pas le suspense on
l'écoutera savons il faut du matériel
mais il le faut vite c'est aussi
pourquoi au delà des douze césars d'ores
et déjà livrés conformément à vos
demandes j'ai pris la décision pour que
dès les prochaines ce même si césar
additionnel puisse l'être voilà donc si
césar additionnel c'est vrai qu'on est
très très loin de la campagne
législative avec tout ça on est loin et
en même temps beaucoup ça bien en même
temps en même temps on n'est jamais si
loin que ça vous savez qu'une des
principales progressions la campagne
s'était notamment l'inflation sur les
produits alimentaires eh ben c'est une
crise alimentaire est ce que c'est le
président français est ce que c'est le
président français de l'union européenne
en tout cas emmanuel macron en a parlé à
kiev la crise alimentaire mondiale que
nous traversons est une conséquence
directe de la guerre menée par la russie
elle n'a pas d'autre explication
il lui rappelle d'ailleurs que les
sanctions qui ont été successivement
prises par les européens ne touche pas
les produits agricoles
contrairement à ce qu a souvent été dit
d'envoyer en interne assisté une
séquence historique aujourd'hui à kiev
et du coup je me faire bizarre quand on
va retrouver tout à l'heure ne profère
pas tout à l'heure vendredi le président
matheron salon viva tech les start up
par les nouvelles technologies je passe
dans quel état d'esprit on sera ce qu'on
pensera encore à l'ukraine ou est ce
qu'on sera essentiellement consacrée sur
le second tour on va garder cette
question de savoir si oui ou non il ya
un agenda
dit merci beaucoup merci stéphane
général franco avant de revenir sur les
annonces et notamment votre expertise
c'est évidemment les militaires la
question des canons caesar je voudrais
avoir votre sentiment vous avez regardé
les images vous avez écouté il n'y avait
pas que macron il y avait aussi c'est
important le président du conseil
italien qu'est ce qui vous a le plus
marqué on parle de visite historique
après tout d'autres chefs d'état et de
gouvernement sont venus est-ce que ce
qualificatif est justifiée légitime oui
je pense qu'il est parfaitement
justifiée pour deux raisons la première
c'est que l'europe discuté beaucoup
autour de la de
l'opposition à la russie puisque au
soutien et l'ukraine tout le monde et
soutenait l'ukraine mais l'opposition à
la russie était diversement discuter
entre les pays j'allais dire de l'est
anciennement occupé par l'union
soviétique et les pays de l'ouest et
symptomatiquement l'allemagne et
l'italie étaient des pays qui avaient
des difficultés en particulier parce
qu'ils sont très dépendants sur le plan
énergétique et chaque fois qu'on a
discuté les package il ya eu des
discussions sur ce sujet là là l'image
donc des trois présidents des grosses
économies européennes il faut le dire
plus
oui et plus de la roumanie qui est sur
la ligne de front et que le président
avait visité la veille avec les troupes
françaises qui sont déployés là-bas ça
monte l'unique eelv europe l'unité de
l'europe qui acceptent la candidature
alors évidemment c'est pas demain mais
ça veut dire la lumière au bout du
tunnel pour les ukrainiens et ça veut
dire aussi que les européens se sont mis
d'accord et que la commission et la
discussion qui aura lieu à la fin du
mois va probablement entériner cette
position c'est pour ça que je pense que
c'est historique l'europe soutient le
cren dans son combat contre la russie et
c'était important de le signaler comme
ça par ce déplacement à kiev était très
attendu en fait cette visite et elle a
été annoncée puis reportée il y avait un
mystère sur le calendrier elle arrive à
la toute fin de la présidence française
de l'union européenne
il faut aller voir il faut aller voir le
président français a fait une petite
vidéo d'hier pin sur son compte twitter
pour montrer l'état évidemment des des
immeubles effondrés c'est une ville qui
a été dévastée ça peut changer
l'état d'esprit d'un dirigeant qui va
décider on se souvient de joe biden qui
était allé à la frontière polonaise
c'est là qu'il avait traité va lire
poutine de bonne chère vous vous
souvenez de boucher et à l'époque je
dois dire qu'on s'en souvient emmanuel
macron trouve être le moins ne convenait
pas du tout alors peut-être que il a eu
lui même un choc à irvine chez moi et
j'aime beaucoup la photo qu'il frappait
d'abord par cette photo que vous nous
avez montré les quatre personnes en
costume trois personnes en costume et un
t-shirt kaki qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire vous êtes la cool moi je
suis en guerre c'est ça que ça veut dire
c'est très important cette photo on n'a
pas l'habitude de voir une scène comme
ça je pense qu'elle restera dans
l'histoire cette photo et puis il ya
deux photos qui ont été prises dans ce
dépassement qui m'ont marqué parce
qu'elles disent beaucoup de choses une
photo des diètes blonde et où il est à
travers une sorte de pare brise d'une
voiture à epinay y voit le regard de des
manières macro qui regardent la voiture
et c'est là moi je me suis dit cette
photo elle veut dire ça j'ai un choc je
vois quelque chose il ya une autre photo
extraordinaire de ludovic marin de la fp
où on voit emmanuel mâcon qui passe son
bras au dessus de l'épaule de jeux
d'hiver de volodymyr geslin ce qui est
le regard de deux dynasties qui ne
regarde rien et on imagine un peu la
bulle au dessus du dip mon moi j'attends
j'attends de voir et en même temps quand
on écoute la conférence de presse d'un
son et jeu on est frappé par le nombre
de questions et notamment des
journalistes ukrainiens sur les mots
prononcés par emmanuel macron ce fameux
mode humiliation il appelait à ne pas
humilier la russie il le fait depuis
longtemps à ne pas céder à l'esprit de
revanche vis-à-vis de la russie beaucoup
de questions il ya même un mot qui a été
inventé en ukrainien ma chronique c'est
à dire discuter pour rien est-ce que
vous avez l'impression que cette visite
elle efface ça ou pas alors l'impression
dominante à mon sens c'est que
effectivement
emmanuel macron à dans cette séquence
réussie grosso modo à puurai l'essentiel
des contentieux des litiges lexicaux et
politiques avec zelensky vous allez on
se souvient tous du tramway nommé désir
de tennessee williams là c'était quand
même un peu le train couchettes nommé
enfin on était vraiment en forme et donc
le train couchettes nommé enfin je
prends le temps de voile à 10h et la
forme et on était dans le temps
additionnel très franchement il n'y
avait pas l arrêt trop tardive on a
parlé beaucoup on a invoqué les concepts
de le moment venu en temps utile
efficacité utilité
assez énigmatique pour moi parce que au
fond les dizaines d'heures de d'échangés
téléphoniques avec l'animal poutine dont
ils étaient utiles je n'en n'ai pas la
conviction donc il était temps il est le
fan de la fenêtre de tir étaient de plus
en plus étroite cela dit moi ce qui me
frappe chez emmanuel macron qui est au
fond un jeune cadre à génère qui n'a
aucune connaissance intime de ce qu'est
la guerre
à ces ma perception tous cas tort ou à
raison mais qui a un rapport au pouvoir
qui reste ludique transgressif et et
rationnelle là il touche du doigt
quelque chose qui lui est étranger et
vous savez on a tous les renseignements
nos services sont là pour ça ils font
plutôt pas mal leur boulot et les
diplomates itou mais quand vous n'avez
pas tâté de ce qu'est l'épaisseur la
densité du silence quand vous êtes dans
un lieu de mémoire c'est pour être
oradour sur glane en france ça peut être
le sanctuaire de guy sosie à kigali
référence bien sûr au génocide de 94 au
rwanda et bien il y a toute une
dimension humaine émotionnel instinctive
que vous ne saisissez pas et je ne crois
pas que il y eut un bouleversement chez
lui mais j'observe quand même qu' il y à
certaines inhibitions lexical dont il
s'est libéré depuis il y à la victoire
il ne renonce pas il ne prononcera pas à
mon sens le mot génocide il persiste à
éviter de qualifier poutine de dictateur
parce qu'ils pensent l'après guerre on
peut pas lui en faire grief le hic avec
lui c'est qu'ils semblent oublier que
avant l'après guerre il ya la guerre et
que c'est là où on est aujourd'hui alors
je je vais quand même faire réagir
d'abord je salue l'arrivée de richard
wehrli sur ce plateau bienvenue richard
mais quand même madame la députée de la
majorité trop qu ils craignent n va les
réformes sociales ce que nous dit
vincent le jeu c'est vraiment enfin et
voilà la page des différends des
polémiques peut se tourner mais
difficilement il va rester des traces
josé lins ce qu'il est que la page est
tournée aujourd'hui donc si le président
ukrainien accepte les positions de
emmanuel macron c'est qu'il estime que
la situation a été clarifiée pendant cet
échange ensuite effectivement les
ukrainiens avaient jugé très durement
les prises de paroles des manuels macron
et ce depuis qu'il a réunies et les sept
membres de l'union européenne à
versailles parce que l'on est prégnant
estimé que le langage des macros
n'étaient pas très claires et où où il
était comment dirais-je pas fermes et
pas assez ferme vis-à-vis de la russie
aujourd'hui c'est chose faite c'est
chose faite mais là il a exprimé comme
la députée de continuer si c'était
nécessaire at il dit a parlé à vladimir
poutine vous le soutenez le message n'a
jamais été exclue évidemment le dialogue
diplomatique ne devait jamais être rompu
essaye manuellement ou l'a défendu bec
et ongles si plus personne a plaidé me
routine il n'y aura pas de discussions
diplomatiques il n'y aura pas des
changes pour l'instant vladimir poutine
ont refusé d'échanger avec des
mercenaires qui directement donc le seul
lien que on a aujourd'hui entre
l'occident qui se tient les prennent et
vladimir poutine c'est la voix
d'emmanuel matheron alors oui on peut
dire que c'est des échanges pour rien
oui on peut dire que ses deux autres
fils trop fréquents qui est mais à me
donner cela va fonctionner elle n'est
pas en
voie de répéter dans la conférence de
presse qui doutaient de de l'utilité de
ces coups de fil et les a même un peu un
peu condamné très clairement richard
wery qu'est ce qui vous a marqué vous
dans dance est dans cette visite je
crois que sur l'aspect ils ont emmanuel
macron au soutien et les skis tout a été
dit et vincent l'a très bien dit moi je
retiens quand même trois questions qui
sont toujours sans réponse et qui
immanquablement vont poser des problèmes
premièrement c'est cette feuille de
route parce que d'un côté on dit
candidat immédiat mais de l'autre
feuille de route qu'est ce qu'on va
mettre dans cette feuille de route parce
que dans une feuille de route on peut
mettre des choses qui vont mécontenter
les ukrainiens et qu'ils ont faites vos
contredire le statut de candidat
immédiat donc je crois que là le sommet
de la semaine prochaine à bruxelles va
être très intéressant la deuxième chose
mais là je me tourne vers le général je
crois qu'en matière de livraisons
d'armes par les annonces des manades
macro il n'y a pas eu beaucoup
d'annoncés durant cette visite et il me
semble que les ukrainiens ont encore des
raisons d'être frustré d'être inquiet vu
ce qui se passe dans le dos de basse et
enfin quand même une question de
politique générale
qui avait aujourd'hui la capitale de
l'union européenne on peut presque dire
ça c'est à dire c'est là que les choses
se passent et 7 ce changement techno
tectoniques il n'est pas sans poser de
problème et si on en revient aux photos
et à rien d'en parler
volodymyr zelensky en homme de guerre on
pourrait dire en chef de guerre on a
quand même l'impression que c'est lui
maintenant qui dirige les opérations on
a presque l'impression que c'est lui qui
est en position de force par rapport à
ceux qui lui ont rendu visite or la
réalité on sait bien que c'est pas celle
là il est en position de faiblesse et
c'est quand même l'allemagne l'italie et
la france qui reste en pole et chanteurs
sont faibles intentions d équilibre et
attention parce que l'union européenne
s'est rappelons le quand même toujours
un édifice assez fragile et là les
dominos me semble aller vite dans pas
rentrer dans le détail si je voulais
bien position de faiblesse en tout cas
militaire je crois que là c'est certain
quand on entend les notes des
renseignements militaires américains on
comprend qu'il ya plus de munitions dont
comme ça c'est clair et puis et puis les
soldats eux mêmes le disent alors si
canon caesar de plus est-ce que ça va
suffire on va faire le point sur la
guerre de l'armement côté ukrainien avec
kathia gilder regardez
c'est une note du renseignement
américain qui l'affirment kiev aurait
épuisé l'intégralité de son stock
d'armes et de
confirmation ukrainienne du chef adjoint
des services secrets dans une interview
au quotidien britannique guardian
pour une pièce d'artillerie ukrainienne
la russie on dispose de 10 à 15 pour 5
sentir côté russe il y à 50 à 60 frappes
de riposte côté ukrainien
résultat la résistance de l'armée
ukrainienne dépend désormais presque
essentiellement des armes occidentales
voici les drones américains tout juste
livrés à cette unité déployée dans le
donbass qu'une équipe de france 2 a pu
filmer il guide les artilleurs déployés
dans la zone pro russe on les voit ici
tirer avec ses canons hérités de
l'ancienne ère soviétique
cela ne suffira pas pour inverser le
rapport de forces sur le terrain ces
images satellites américaine montre à
quoi ressemble le déluge de feu sur la
ville assiégée de severodonetsk pour
résister à cette intense pilonnage kiev
a donc besoin d'armes lourdes
les ukrainiens dépend le césar de
lourdes seul moyen pour eux de résister
à la brutale invasion russe depuis 2014
des alliés de l'otan ont formé et équipé
des dizaines de milliers de soldats us
craignent un des officiers qui sont
maintenant en première ligne
la france a livré pour 100 millions
d'euros d'équipement militaire et ses
premiers canons caesar de 155 mm
capables de tirer 6 coups par minute à
une distance de 40 km
les allemands ont donné des missiles sol
air stinger et des armes anti char mais
les livraisons se font au compte-gouttes
et quand les armes arrivent enfin sur
zone elles doivent être adaptées pour
servir à l'armée ukrainienne autre
faiblesse le moral des troupes épuisé
alors que les soldats combattent sur
1200 km au 110e jours de guerre les
désertions se multiplient et sur le
front chaque jour l'hécatombe jusqu'à
300 soldats d'ukrainiens tués selon kiev
jamais un train quand est ce que le
crâne est en train de la perdre cette
bataille de l'armement et ce qui s'est
décidée aujourd'hui vous semble de
nature à changer le cours des choses ou
pas or je pense qu'aujourd'hui le
changement de stratégie russe
concentration des efforts sur le donbass
est en train de payer et la russie est
en train de gagner la guerre du donbass
gagnerons la guerre mais la bataille de
nombreux si la gagne deuxièmement sur
les plans de l'armement il faut faire
très attention entre le moment où on
annonce qu'on envoie de l'armement et le
moment où effectivement il peut tirer
alors pour revenir simplement la
question des frais l'artillerie
française les 18 16 heures c'est sûr
qu'à eux seuls ils reverseront pas la
donne mais ils participent et ils sont
très efficaces les ukrainiens l'ont
montré ont montré beaucoup de vidéos sur
le détail elle une très très forte
précision
le gros avantage c'est que c'est une
mise en batterie extrêmement rapide et
une sortie de batteries extrêmement
rapide ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que vous arrivez vous avez un drone qui
vous a donné les coordonnées le mettait
en batterie une minute après étire six
obus en une minute et il repart
immédiatement donc l'artillerie russe
n'est pas capable de faire une
contrepétrie alors que les autres pièces
qui sont beaucoup moins vu le nom
qu'on peut mais - vous passer de temps
sur le terrain - vous êtes visé alors
que l'autre a retiré qu'on a vu le temps
de la mise en place du tir du retrait de
batteries etc il faut accrocher un
camion etc c'est extrêmement lourd et
donc c'est beaucoup plus vulnérables
donc quand je dis qu'il contribue au
sein de l'artillerie ça veut dire que
leur objectif principal c'est le tir de
contre batterie et simplement quand on
met en parallèle les tirs russes et les
tirs ukrainien on mélange des poires à
l'époque le la russie elle matraque tout
le terrain qui est des civils qui est
pas de civils qui et n'importe quoi elle
bombarde elle bombarde elle bombarde la
retirer ukrainienne s'est pas du tout
son objet son objet c'est de taper
précisément sur les cibles russes au
milieu de la population parfois au
milieu sur un territoire qui est art et
territoire ukrainien donc on est dans
des situations complètement différente
mais maintenant pour parler de la
situation aujourd'hui parce qu on a
l'impression que là
c'est david contre goliath un peu un
luxe mais une seule une pièce
d'artillerie contre 10 à 15 quater oui
mais elle n'en porte contre goliath new
look mais mes et salé depuis le début
mais le problème c'est un problème de
stratégie aujourd'hui quand je vois
l'armée ukrainienne qui se bat mordicus
à ses vrais donesk la carte la rate
logiquement se passer la porte d'entrée
oui dont bas mais c'est un combat perdu
sur lequel ils perdent des hommes ils
perdent des équipements et qu'ils
feraient mieux de consacrer c'est avoir
la glace ont organisé ça veut dire que
pour vous c'est il faut se retirer
il faut monter une ligne de défense à un
endroit où vous pouvez défendre si
marion denay c'est juste à l'est de la
rivière c'est dans un creux c'est dominé
par des auteurs de l'autre côté qui sont
à l'ouest de la rivière la rivière fait
80 m elle ne put ton tous les ponts ont
été cassées donc non pas cette carte
d'odessa c'est vous placez la précédente
carte où on voit tout le temps de basses
raisons donc ça veut dire ça veut dire
globalement pour parler de terre
militaire il s'agit pas de tenir la
rivière mai d'interdire sur
franchissement elad organisé par
ailleurs tous les mâts tels qu'ils sont
reçus son différend avec des systèmes
différents il faut coordonner tous et on
a l'impression que les soldats sont peu
formés alors elle et des papiers oui
découvre la notice avec google
traduction hors jeu pour les autres je
ne sais pas pour ceux qui sont venus en
france c'était des artistes
oui et les français m'ont dit
remarquable ils ont très bien compris
savent très bien s'en servir donc si
vous voulez ya le problème c'est de
coordonner tout ça entre les césar les
mlrs les et ccd système compliqué et ça
se fait pas sur le front c'est pour ça
que je dis moi je comprends les
ukrainiens ils défendent leur terre
natale ils ne veulent pas céder un pouce
de terrain moralement je le comprends
mais stratégiquement il ya des choix à
faire et les r je pense qu'aujourd'hui
c'est pas bon d'ailleurs le gouverneur
de louhansk a dit je ne peux plus on est
en train de perdre trop d'hommes le
président à se resserrer les boulons le
lendemain il a dit je suis capable de
reprendre ces données sans 48 heures
tout le monde sait que c'était faux donc
si vous voulez faut faut faire la part
des choses entre le côté très
pragmatique du combat et puis l'aspect
un peu
symbolique de la éléphants d'un certain
car ça c'est le stratège militaire qui
parle sauf qu'après il ya des hommes il
ya une nation c'est audible ça en gros
il faudrait peut-être arrêter de fixer à
l'entrée du dombass assez véronneau desk
pour aller plus
depuis reagan depuis l'échec cinglant du
blitzkrieg initial la guerre éclair
fantasmé par par le kremlin on est entré
dans une forme de guerre hybride mais de
guérir hybride du siècle dernier et
c'est à dire à la fois course contre la
montre et guerre d'usure et donc là en
l'occurrence l'idée est de tenir le
temps nécessaire pour que l'acheminement
et la mise en oeuvre des armements
sophistiqués en question et puise un peu
à fléchir le cours de rallye et en la
chaîne mais attention on est quand même
ici dans un combat de deux épuisement
parce qu'on parle et d'ailleurs kiev le
fait avec une certaine transparence qui
a aussi pour vocation d'éviter tout
relâchement de ses parrains occidentaux
mais de l'autre côté c'est pas beaucoup
mieux et si vous voulez l'accumulation
de bouches à feu comme disent les
militaires en jargon ne suffit pas non
plus à gagner la guerre je prends un
exemple très simple
vous avez effectivement de l'autre côté
de la rivière donne est la ville jumelle
de les sites chance donc est un peu la
cité jumelle de severodonetsk la veine
topographiques est plutôt favorable à ce
que vous avez des auteurs et c'est vrai
que si vous êtes capable de construire
ce qu'on appelle une ligne dure six de
défense et on peut pas exclure que ce
soit le cas vous pouvez très nettement
entraver l'avancée des russes pour moi
le fait que le verrou de severodonetsk
sauterait ne signifie même pas la fin de
la guerre du donbass par rapport par
rapport à ce qu'on entend dire
basse
tombé il ya quand même des éléments
objectifs paraissent de prograf i et
puis il ya toujours cette question
cardinale d'après les experts du
ministère britannique de la défense qui
est la capacité ou pas de franchissement
des cours d'eau et quand je parle de
franchissement c'est pas à gué ou sur
une passerelle avec des hommes et leur
sac à dos non je parle de franchissement
avec des engins lourds blindés des
pièces d'artillerie donc c'est pour ça
que à mon sens là mais ce fut selon le
rite orthodoxe
aryenne schéma quand on regarde la
réaction des russes il faut toujours
regarder ce que dit moscou sur une
journée aussi importante en symboles
quatre chefs d'état c'est pas rien alors
on a on a ce tweet de dimitri medvedev
je vous le site les amateurs européens
de grenouilles c'est pour nous deux
saucisses ça c'est pour les allemands
j'imagine et de spaghetti pour les
italiens adorent visiter kiev avec zéro
résultat adhésion promis à l'union
européenne et vieux au but à l'ukraine
pourtant ça ne rapprochera pas l'ukraine
de la paix l'horloge tourne oui il
rajoute d'ailleurs ils viennent en train
ça prend beaucoup de temps et absolument
pas grave vu que la vérité c'est
exactement ce que d'user richard c'est à
dire que je pense que kiev effectivement
il voulu symboliquement la capitale de
l'europe et ça ça commence à des agaches
et donc sur le ton de l'humour la
légèreté c'est quand même pas très
hautement diplomatique comme tweet c'est
moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est en plus intéressant que celle de m
medvedev c'est quand même la doublure de
poutine c'est lui qui le dit donc on
voit quand même je trouve
un certain agacement et c'est vrai que
en gros il dit ben voilà ça défile et
c'est vrai que ça défile sur le ce qui
me frappe moi je suis évidemment bien
incapable de juger si la stratégie
militaire de
dégrader la bonne je n'y connais rien
mais ce qui me frappe c'est la
passion avec lesquels les français et
parle de stratégie militaire où il ya
une fois une blague qui m'a frappé quand
j'étais à kiev disait voilà il ya quatre
mois quand on disait je suis craignant
dans les pays européens où vous habitez
en russie est maintenant quand il dit je
fais craignant les gens vous demande
vous êtes des cas l'oblast oui et c'est
vrai qu'on est tous devenus des espèces
de petits spécialistes les élus cré de
créer la mairie capitale régionale ils
attendent toute l'europe oui ils
essayent quand même dans l'eure dans
leur état d'esprit dans leurs discours
de se dire on ne compte que sur nous les
députés et les ministres continuent à
l'aider qu'ils ne peuvent à bruxelles
parce que c'est important pour eux alors
que c'est évidemment des heures de
voyage ils suivent les ukrainiens avec
une vraiment un intérêt très grand
intérêt des élections les élections
législatives françaises et comprennent
pas ils n'ont pas compris la
présidentielle il m'a regardé parmi les
candidats le nombre de gens qui sont pro
russe ils ont raison c'est sidérant pour
une comprennent pas et puis donc ça
c'est vrai ils peuvent vous dire le
moindre petit bougé de raphaël
glucksmann sera enregistrée chez les
ukrainiennes pour dire oui pourquoi
comment il peut être ni baisse c'est ça
ma frappe et ça ils connaissent
parfaitement la carte géopolitique enfin
la pac carte politique de la france
enfin là je parle de la france parce que
je suis française mais j'imagine que
j'aimerais aussi pour d'autres pays
vincent gérer gm de dmitri medvedev
valent le détour il fut un temps pas si
lointain où il apparaissait comme plutôt
quelqu'un de modéré ouvert vers vers
l'occident appuyé dans ses stands goût
de pouvoir premier ministre président
pour les ministres et cetera avec son
compère poutine et le fait qu'il recoure
lui à cette sémantique là est assez
significatif c'est quand même le troadec
saisi par la débauche fa lui c'est un
medvedev saisi par la radicalité quoi
sur le tas mais ça dit quelque chose que
l'on observe à mon avis assez peu en
occident c'est que poutine au fond est
moins menacée par un élan pacifistes ont
cherché encore les premiers indices que
par oprah une fuite en avant radical et
donc medvedev est assez
fidèlement l'incarnation de ce phénomène
virtuel pour l'union européenne ya quand
même deux défis là après cette visite le
premier défi vous savez qu une des
plaies de l'union européenne depuis
toujours et parce qu'elle est structuré
ainsi c'est le trop peu trop tard c'est
quand même une spécialité de l'europe et
on le sait tout le monde le sait donc
comment vis-à-vis de l'ukraine ça va se
passer parce qu'il faut pas qu'il y ait
trop peu il faut pas que ça arrive trop
tard et donc qu'elle connaît alors avec
6 paquet de sanctions trop peu trop tard
mais c'est difficile parce qu'il y ait
ici même hier dans votre chronique même
dans votre chronique même s'il veut il y
allait on savait pas à l'époque il irait
ou pas que c'était déjà trop tard oui je
pense qu'il y à il y à ça et l'autre
chose qui me frappe et ça va de pair
c'est que l'union européenne aujourd'hui
la commission demain va rendre son avis
sur la candidature on va parler etc mais
pourquoi il n'y a pas aujourd'hui un
commissaire européen en charge de
l'ukraine moi j'aimerais bien savoir il
ya 27 commissaires européens vous avez
pas venir qui en a pas un qui peut être
entièrement chargée d'ukraine sachant
que c'est la cause majeure on pourrait
imaginer que deux commissaires européens
à plein-temps s'occupe de l'ukraine
parce qu'il ya quand même une chose dont
on parle pas du tout c'est l'économie et
c'est la vie quotidienne de ce pays
comment il va faire pour tenir il n'y a
pas que la ligne de front il ya
l'arrière il ya la nécessité pour ce
pays de continuer à produire de nourrir
sa population ça peut pas être une
perfusion parce que plus l'ukraine sera
sous perfusion total plus ça posera des
questions
naturellement ce qu'ils soutiennent dont
le jeu je m'inquiète quand même de la
logistique c'est facile d'aller dire
candidats immédiat c'est ce serait
peut-être mieux par moment de prendre
des vraies décisions et de dire à une
partie de l'administration à bruxelles
votre boulot maintenant c'est l'ukraine
de travail et les clés du crâne alors
justement belle transition vous parlez
de l'économie l'ukraine s'est beaucoup
une terre agricole on va parler de ce
qui se passe dans le port d'odessa
l'enjeu c'est de lever ce blocus du port
pour acheminer des tonnes de millions de
blé vers l'afrique pour empêcher les
famines écouter le chef de l'état nous
appelons donc solennellement
ensemble depuis kiev la russie membre
permanent du conseil de sécurité
a accepté que les nations unies
organisent l'exportation des céréales ce
qui nécessitent d'accepter
de lever le blocus des ports ukrainiens
par la marine russe est d'apporter
toutes les garanties de sécurité
pour l'ukraine afin de permettre
justement la sortie de céréales general
trinquant alors là la france a fait déjà
quelques jours a proposé une aide
technique pour
sécuriser les cargos qui sortirait du
port a expliqué que la mer est minée par
les russes et par les ukrainiens pour y
arriver il faut que moscow jours de jeu
est ce qu'on peut on peut leur faire
confiance bien sûr alors alors alors
leur faire confiance il ya des modalités
pour leur faire confiance mais bien sûr
qu'il faut que les russes jouent le jeu
sans l'accord russo on ne peut pas je
note que tout ceci arrive après la
visite de macky sall président de en
exercice de l'union africaine président
du sénégal qui est allé voir moscou et
retour il est passé en france et là à
mon sens il avait l'air à mon sens les
garanties oui mais ont des garanties et
que
les promesses n'engagent que ceux qui
les écoutent
la seule promesse qui vaudra et le
président de la république en parle en
parlant du membre permanent du conseil
de sécurité c'est une résolution de
l'onu que votre et la russie et qui donc
serait engageante pour la russie en
disant on va monter une opération pour
sortir ces grains alors ça c'est le côté
diplomatique qui doit associer les
ukrainiens les russes et les turcs et
bien sûr le conseil de sécurité avec
deux dans trois pays européens qui sont
trois pays africains pardon qui sont
conseil de sécurité qui ont déjà pris
langue pour remonter cette opération
ensuite il ya les modalités techniques
or là évidemment les modalités
techniques que me dit à marin c'est
compliqué je l'aï dit est ce que c'est
possible de dire marin c'est votre
boulot hein c'est cessa déminage c'est à
dire reconnaissance alors d'abord
chose
mines ya les mines qui sont identifiés
donc ça a retiré on sait faire ça
s'appelle du dragage domine et puis
ensuite il ya les mines non identifiée
c'est à dire qu'elle celles qui ont
dérivé on sait que sur la france sur les
rivages turc on a déjà retrouvé des
mines qui avait dérivé donc là eh ben ça
monte demande une manoeuvre oudoire est
associé les turcs je rappelle celle
toute la rive sud de la mer noire et
surtout le contrôle des détroits or pour
faire venir des bateaux de déminage il
va falloir passer par les détroits et
puis ensuite ceci va permettre quoi et
bien simplement tout bêtement que les
assureurs qui vont assurer les bateaux
qui vont aller chercher le gras qui sont
des bateaux commerciaux initial et si ya
pas de résolution de l'onu ci a pas de
paix les assureurs ne vont
alors la confiance c'est acquérir auprès
des russes par un non pas des paroles
mais par une signature sur une
résolution enfin c'est peut-être l'homme
de l'onu qui tient non mais c'est très
clair une résolution sinon je vois pas
quelle confiance on peut accorder aux
russes les choses se débloquent vous le
voyez comme ça c'est un enjeu central a
évidemment c'est terrible pour les
ukrainiens mais potentiellement d'ici
quelques mois ce sont des famines le mot
n'est pas trop fort qui risque d'arriver
quand revenir poutine reçoit voilà deux
semaines à sotchi macky sall donc
présent exercice de l'union africaine il
a cette phrase ébouriffante lui dit mais
il n'y a aucun problème pour exporter
les céréales ukrainienne il ya déjà des
facto une annexion du potentiel agricole
d'un pays réputé souverain deuxièmement
ce qui fonctionne deux côtés de poutine
c'est le chantage alimentaire dire qu'il
a réussi à embarquer dans une forme de
neutralité actif une bonne partie des
pays subsahariens et d'autres nations
comme l'égypte évidemment la tunisie en
faisant miroiter
grande tradition soviétique
goldau mort l'extermination par la fin
entre 1931 et 1933
c'est au fond alors là sur le mode du
châtiment et non pas sur le mode du
chantage
utilisation forcer une sorte de
rébellion de jacquerie des paysans on
appelle les koulaks les paysans prospère
ils ne sont pas tous régnât staline fait
encercler par son armée les villages et
jusqu'à ce que mort s'ensuive mais ça
n'est pas une image au sens littéral du
terme les gens crèvent de faim 7
millions de morts d'après les historiens
aujourd'hui donc environ 5 millions
d'ukrainiens dont je dire ça ça
appartient je dirais aux fantasmes
soviéto impériaux de poutine donc il y à
quelque chose d'assez navrant quand on
voit qu'une partie de l'intelligentsia
africaine achète cette imposture alors
que et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui est très
intéressant ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui géré jusque là dessus c'est
que à un moment donné et même acron dit
rappelons nous que l'unique responsable
de ce péril de la famine c'est
l'agresseur et en cela il est absolument
imparable évidemment l autre dossier
très sensible vous l'avez largement
évoqué reichert c'est l'entrée alors est
ce qu'on doit dire ça ou la candidature
de l'ukraine dites-nous si au fond voilà
c'était pas gagné est-ce que c'est pas
un vrai un vrai progrès est ce qu'il ya
une victoire de l'ukraine ce soir à dire
oui ça y est on va être pays candidats
ça devrait être une formalité on aura
l'unanimité des 27 pour pour leur donner
ce statut plus d'un comme ça et il dans
votre commentaire on peut penser que si
les quatre dirigeants qui étaient actifs
aujourd'hui se sont engagés là dessus
par la voix d'emmanuel macron président
en exercice de l'union européenne a
priori ça a été discuté je pense qu'ils
y sont pas allées qui n'ont pas
simplement discuter tous les trois donc
même pour être candidat il ya des
conditions il faut bien évidemment
respecter les valeurs de l'union
européenne étape 3 indépendance de la
justice liberté de la je crois et l
économie de marché viable
symboliquement c'est symboliquement
c'est gagné pour l'ukraine là
aujourd'hui symboliquement vis-à-vis de
l'union européenne l'ukraine en
l'occurrence le président hélène ce qui
a marqué un point énorme on lui dit vous
serez un candidat immédiat c'est unique
il n'y a pas eu de candidature immédiat
gagne du temps mais de toute façon il ya
les années voire des danses et les gagne
plus que du tout et il y a une plus que
du temps parce que d'abord il passe
alors voir ce qui va se passer avoue sa
semaine prochaine mais il passe devant
un certain nombre de pays ça c'est plus
que gagner du temps c'est gagner des
places littéralement sahiron on est
devant et et l'autre chose quand même il
gagne un ascendant ça c'est important
parce que tout ça c'est quand même de la
politique la difficulté et j'en viens à
ce que je disais à propos de la
commission européenne c'est que
l'ukraine n'est pas un pays dans une
situation normale aujourd'hui les autres
les autres candidats ce sont dans une
situation à peu près normal de paix on
peut discuter avec eux de règles de
droit d'état de droit de lutte
anticorruption qui va aller aujourd'hui
et on ne sait pas combien de temps la
guerre va durer dire au présent et en
ski ou à son ministre de la justice que
je ne connais pas là ça va pas ça ça va
pas ça sera pas la réponse immédiate
sera excusez nous on a d'autres choses à
faire en ce moment on a une guerre a
gagné donc il ya un problème le dialogue
politique avec l'ukraine aujourd'hui de
facto il est totalement biaisé et pour
bien comprendre évidemment c'est
politique c'est important aussi de les
symboles l'exemple ils veulent entrer
dans l'europe il se bat aussi pour les
valeurs de l'ordre mais est-ce que si on
était dans une candidature normal ils
n'auraient pas accès à ces conditions et
a droit
lorsqu'on les années 70 ce qui était à
l'époque la communauté économique
européenne accueille la grèce qui sort
tout juste la grande nuit du régime des
colonels et l'espagne post-franquiste
aucun ces deux pays ne respectent les
normes
il ya aussi des c'est pas tout à fait
sans précédent mais ses attaquants et je
pense aussi qu'il faut être très prudent
je voyais vincent richer la tête en
parlant de la corruption en ukraine qui
est impayée extrêmement corrompu c'est
que l'europe ne peut pas se permettre de
mettre de côté toutes les règles pour
rejoindre l'europe sinon elle n'est plus
l'europe et donc les ukrainiens c'est
une lumière au bout du tunnel mais il ya
quand même un tunnel il ya quand même du
tout d'ailleurs
avec une affaire de fraude fiscale qui
avait défrayé la chronique en ukraine
quelques mois avant devant la gare juste
un mot vincent a raison mais je crois
que l'exemple espagnol et en
l'occurrence et espagne et portugal
l'exemple de l'espagne le pneu justement
moi je ferai une différence espagne et
portugal effectivement il y avait je
dirais une capacité ne serait ce que par
leur localisation géographique y avait
une capacité très forte 2 la communauté
européenne de l'époque à les intégrer la
grèce très franchement disons les choses
comme elles sont même encore aujourd'hui
on peut s'interroger si l'intégration de
la grèce à cette époque et de cette
manière fut une bonne idée ariane chemin
racontez nous cette système cette
machine et l'inscrit parce que c'est
aussi une énorme victoire de tous les
gens qui travaillent avec lui au plus
près il ya les sacs de sable il ya la
peur des attentats vous raconter c'est
très bien dans le papier mais en même
temps la maîtrise de tout un récit
médiatique sur la guerre qui fait qu'on
si on obtient des arbitrages du roman
durement négocié oui en fait l'idée
qu'on ne l'a dit au journal j'ai dit
mais comment on tourne l'ukraine en
temps de guerre on avait envie d'aller
voir un peu au plus près et puis aussi
il faut faire attention parce que c'est
toujours rebondir on parle toujours des
coudes comme deux élastiques et parfois
de manière un peu négative enfin là
comme ça peut être aussi parfois quand
c'est de la communication de crise
entend guère ça peut être très utile là
et ça c'est vrai qu'ils étaient masse à
la matière ce qui m'a frappé c'est que
je sais c'est évidemment ça ressemblait
à tout sauf les images qu'on a pu voir
pendant les mois de février et de mars
on est les caméras telle était beaucoup
dans les campagnes où on voyait les
babouchkas les les petites maisons et là
on est on est presque dans la start-up
d'etion quoi on est dense et le
contraste est fascinant entre ses palais
totalement soviétique d'ailleurs moi
j'adore les lustres un peu soviétique
comme ça je trouve ça très beau il y
avait du cristal de bohême qui venait de
l'ancienne tchécoslovaquie j'imagine et
puis tout d'un coup vous rentrez dans le
bureau par exemple du ministre la
transition numérique et vous allez
présenter dans une salle de fitness
parce que comme il sort pas beaucoup il
fait venir son coach il ya six machines
de fitness une grande table comme dans
les bureaux google j'ai même vu une
espèce de petite casquette joe biden
avec lesquels ils s'amusaient sur un
jeune sur une petite sculpture donc ça
c'est assez frappant de voir le choc
entre les deux et c'est vrai que
l'ukraine je peux être que les français
ne le savent pas encore beaucoup mais
c'est une api qui est très en avance
numériquement c'est à dire par exemple
celle 1 ce qui s'était fait élire à sa
formule c'est qu'il aime bien les choses
qui vont vite il avait dit je vais faire
je vais goudronner les routes et puis il
crée une sorte d'application qui
s'appelle dia qui vous permet sur notre
téléphone par exemple de renouveler pas
de portable votre permis de conduire en
deux jours d'avoir tous vos papiers avec
vous c'est quand même merveilleux c'est
super bien et d'ailleurs comme ils sont
inventifs au gouvernement et qui
s'adapte et bien par exemple ces
applications échappe elle sert
aujourd'hui vous photographier votre
maison détruite et puis vous allez vous
accélérer le rythme des indemnisations
donc ça c'est un pays hyper connectés
c'est un président de soit 0 et c'est
d'ailleurs filmé willem au volant il
avait complètement désacralisé la
fonction aussi une fois une fois au
pouvoir en vidant les journalistes
quasiment à répondre au téléphone oui
oui oui bah il a désacralisé par exemple
les bureaux des ministres vous avez ce
qu'on n'est pas obligé de mettre la
photo de classe qui ont peu mais on
n'est pas obligé c'est pas voilà et
c'est vrai que il ya une côte à côte et
sa course à pied au début évidemment
quand arrivent les chars russes il faut
bien dire que l'ukraine ne s'attend pas
du tout c'est comme ça voilà retenir
qu'il faut retenir de cette histoire
donc tout de suite ils font des réunions
de députés façon flash mob alors les
députés sont là ils ont l'habitude ils
ont leurs manies de sur lui déjà chez
eux parce qu'il faut pas oublier que du
crédit est en guerre depuis 2000 14 ans
qui se voit d'habitude ils ont aussi
savent déjà très pertinemment ce qu'il
faut faire en cas d'actes ap tout le
monde se réunit à la rada le président
est allé se faire signer le le président
du parlement et à les faire signer le
décret au préau ag reims qui est
immédiatement après bien se tiennent des
assemblées comme ça sur des groupes
c'est un point que vous ne verrez pas du
tout abattu en fait hyper réactif
combatif organisé presque enthousiaste à
vous entendre on touche à ce nom c'est
moi qui suis enthousiaste parce que ça
m'a fasciné il avait intéressé
enthousiaste j'ai quand même pas très
marrant mais c'est quand même déjà
jugeant très fatigué qui ne demandait
pas la nuit qui sont là tout le temps
avec toujours ya quand même toujours
même s'ils ne se passe plus rien à kiev
le bruit des sirènes trois ou quatre
fois par jour là la nécessité décembre
dans les abris ça reste mais c'est vrai
que l'on a si ce matin on a l'impression
qu'il ya une organisation voilà très
c'est à dire est que c'est une
dérégulation de résistance qu'est ce qui
s'est passé il faut pas oublier que les
français les américains ont proposé à
celle inscrite s'en aller il est resté y
incarne un mot un peu désuet mais qui
reprend la valeur le courage on savait
qu'il était voilà la cible de plusieurs
attentats déjoués au début de la guerre
c'est toujours le cas aujourd'hui
alors vous savez il ya des erreurs et la
différence je préfère je ne voudrais pas
avec certitude le nombre d'attentats
auquel il a pu chaput ça défend
évidemment si vous parlez avec les
services secrets ukrainiens ou les
services secrets américains ou d'autres
donc mais c'est vrai que c'est très
surveillé que
on n'est pas censé savoir où se trouve
le président et d'un ski que vous ne
rentrez pas comme ça dans le palais
présidentiel vous devez laisser votre
êtes scanner vous laissez votre portable
il ya ya radio med qui mesurent la
réactivité de l'air et puis vous êtes un
peu dans le noir parce que y'a une
voiture qui vient vous chercher pas
rentrer comme ça on ne rentrent pas dans
un palais présidentiel en temps de
guerre comme à l'elysée aujourd'hui
évidemment alors je voudrais terminer ce
débat en vous ramenant à l'hexagone si
si vous voulez dire va regarder un petit
sujet de léo ce parce que vous avez
évidemment entendu les critiques des
différents leaders politiques en
campagne dans ces législatives qui
apprécient modérément cette visite
regardez
du côté des oppositions c'est
l'unanimité le voyage à kiev d' emmanuel
macron à 72 heures du second tour ne
passe pas pour la france insoumise le
chef de l'état exploitent la situation
et je voudrais pas que le martyre du
peuple ukrainien servent à mathieu mâcon
pour peut-être des opérations de
politique intérieure française personne
n'est dupe sur le fait que c'est à trois
jours que ce déplacement dont on parlait
beaucoup à trois jours du second tour
qui va déterminant pour la vie politique
française que monsieur macron fait des
images avec monsieur des propos dénoncés
par clément bonne le ministre délégué en
charge de l'europe est ce qu'une fois
dans cette campagne chez monsieur
corbières on peut avoir un peu de
hauteur de vue de dignité
quand même froid que le chancelier
scholz il est en campagne après que le
président du conseil italien mario
draghi est en campagne nous sommes à une
semaine d'un sommet européen marine le
pen est à peine plus modérée elle n'a
rien contre cette visite mais fustige
son timing c'est le calendrier qui
interroge ce calendrier interroge
d'autant plus
il a cru bon de faire une déclaration
électoraliste sur le tarmac de
l'aéroport et ce mélange des genres est
effectivement je trouve gênant au regard
du fonctionnement
pour les républicains la place
d'emmanuel macro aujourd'hui est en
france et non en ukraine la maison brûle
et emmanuel macron ils regardent
ailleurs mais qu'est ce que c'est que
cette stratégie d'évitement alors
qu'aujourd'hui son sujet numéro un est
de savoir s'il a une majorité pour
gouverner le pays mais c'est une folie
c'est une folie une telle légèreté dans
ce concert généralisée d'attac contre
emmanuel macron seule la réaction de
gérard larcher est plus modérée je pense
qu'il était temps que le président de la
république aille à kiev aille en ukraine
qu'il ya eu avec le chancelier allemand
et le premier ministre italien est un
symbole il disait il ya un instant trois
pays fondateurs de l'europe qui se voit
rejoint par le président hu a nice c'est
me semble-t-il aussi symbole une image
certes symbolique mais un timing
vivement critiquée en france
général trinquant quel est votre
sentiment sur cette polémique écoutez la
visite de l'union européenne réunis à
kiev était importante c'est compliqué à
monter sa tombe à ce moment là je
rappelle que la semaine prochaine ce
sont les élections législatives et non
pas présidentielle et donc il était
important de marquer cette unité avant
la fin de la présidence française de
l'union européenne
ne peut pas être suspecté de
complaisance envers emmanuel macron mais
je dirais que les égarements
géopolitique de mélenchon d'un côté le
pen de l'autre de la syrie à chavez et
de la russie à castro les disqualifie
définitivement la matière quand vous
restez avec nous vincent très en verve
ce soir merci à vous merci général train
quand richard wehrli ariane chemin à
lire donc dans le monde cette grande
enquête sur au coeur du pouvoir sur le
système zelensky merci merci infiniment
c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos a franchi
pour leur parti pris ce soir
le carnet de campagne des amendes un
gamma qui va nous parler du grand retour
de nicolas sarkozy dans cette campagne
vincent vous allez nous parler de boris
johnson qui n'en démord pas de vous
faire expulser ces migrants vers le
rwanda et puis la sémiologue mariette
darrigrand va revenir sur un mot répété
sur tous les tons par jean luc mélenchon
au soir du premier tour ce mot ses
harmonies ce no a franchi les voici
bonsoir hézard mariette alors on
commence avec votre carnet de campagne
elsa mondain gaba vous nous parlez d'un
bad buzz ce soir oui alors on va dire un
bouche à oreille négatif marié s'émeut
élaguer sur le plateau il vient déjà mme
c'est les jeunes avec macron regardez la
vidéo qui les ont postés hier il s'agit
d'une fiction les jeunes avec macro
imagine la france au lendemain du
deuxième tour des législatives
si jean luc mélenchon à la majorité et
s'il y a un groupe rassemblement
national à l'assemblée on y voit et bien
une jeune femme qui marche dans la rue
qui reçoit des alertes de médias sur son
téléphone attaque aux valeurs
républicaines mise en danger notre
constitution atteinte aux libertés de la
presse alors là il ya un ou une amie qui
lui propose un week-end à marrakech on y
reviendra et puis ça continue sur les
mauvaises nouvelles 20% d'augmentation
du prix de l'énergie partenariat avec la
russie pour le gaz arrêt des subventions
aux médias indépendants manque plus que
l'appui de sauterelles et l'invasion
deux grenouilles et puis à cette jeune
femme bas elle est surtout en colère
parce qu'avec la suppression des vols
hors europe c'en est fini pour ces trois
jours de week-end à marrakech où elle
avait extrêmement critiqué cette vidéo
oui alors déjà les médias ils n'ont pas
du tout apprécié de voir leur nom avec
des fausses informations en dessous
ensuite beaucoup ont dénoncé une
caricature voir une déconnexion avec en
fait cette jeune fille prise de passer
trois jours en week-end à marrakech les
jeunes socialistes et bien ils ont
parodié la parodie en imaginant qu'ils
emmanuel macron s'allie à la droite pour
gouverner
face aux critiques les jeunes avec
macron il on a décidé de supprimer l'isf
et cette vidéo et pour finir ce soir à
elsa une question que beaucoup de
républicains s'opposent à quoi joue
nicolas sarkozy oui puisque l'ancien
président de la république s'est immiscé
dans la campagne des législatives dans
la 4e circonscription de paris et dans
cette circonscription le match il oppose
la députée de droite sortante brigitte
kuster fidèle sarkozyste soutenu par les
figures des républicains rachida dati
xavier bertrand elle est opposée à
astrid panossian bouvet investi par la
majorité et devinez laquelle a été reçu
par nicolas sarkozy et moniste voilà
sinon ce serait pas drôle c'était une
information révélée par le parisien
alors brigitte kuster ça n'a pas fait
rire du tout elle accuse un retard de 12
points sur son adversaire elle a dénoncé
dans le figaro une trahison j'ai honte
pour lui at elle déclaré elle a retweeté
des soutiens reçus par les poids lourds
des républicains gérard larcher eric
ciotti pierre charon valérie boyer ils
sont nombreux en fait à ne plus du tout
comprendre nicolas sarkozy n'a pas
appelé à voter pour valérie pécresse il
a été hué en meeting pour ça là la jeune
génération appel à tourner la page entre
l air et sarkozy le divorce entre bien
conséquent ça m'est passé une manière
aussi pour eux d'arrêter tir référé
peut-être que ça leur permettra de
couper un peu le cordon on verra on
verra à l'avenir mariette alors on a
tous repérés que jean luc mélenchon
dimanche soir n'avaient plus exactement
la même verve le même sens voilà de de
l'art oratoire il avait l'air un peu
éteint mais vous ce qui vous a attiré
voilà interrogé c'est plutôt un mot
c'est ça qui l'a employé ce mot
d'harmonie notamment oui ça m'a surprise
le fait qu'ils emploient le terme
l'harmonie parce que c'est un mot qui
l'a répété en plus je crois qu'on peut
l'entendre
à l'égout tais toi te fenua et il l'a
répété plusieurs fois
ces futurs
d'harmonie entre les êtres humains
débarrasser des domination
sociale culturelle de genre
un futur d'harmonie entre les êtres
humains et avec la nature
alors que vous l'été ça m'a beaucoup
intéressé ce mot harmonie parce que en
fait c'est apparemment ce n'est pas un
mot de la politique c'est plutôt de la
psychologie harmonie de la famille du
couple etc mais en fait et ça va avec
son air grave c'est un mot du
vocabulaire de l'utopie et je crois que
c'est là qu'il est allé le chercher ce
mot un peu surprenant jean luc mélenchon
chez les utopistes socialiste de la fin
du 19ème donc charles proulx dont par
exemple et puis un autre qui s'appelle
charles fourier là c'est là c'est drôle
parce que charles fourier faisait
toujours la tronche en fait il était
absolument sinistre alors qu'il parlait
sans arrêt du bonheur et de la société
idéale donc je crois que c'est cet effet
là qu'on a eue alors fourier en parlait
avec le phalanstère à mesure tout le
monde vivait ensemble et c'est avec la
nuque baisse c'est celle où frau mais
c'est peut-être quelque chose comme ça
mais en tout cas j'ai eu l'impression
que sa gravité venaient de ce retour à
l'origine de la politique en quelque
sorte à dire que l'utopie n'a rien très
très drôle très joyeux c'est grave c'est
une façon de revenir aux origines mêmes
de la politique c'est à dire comment on
organise et parfois de manière assez
autoritaire la société la société idéale
donc il faut les grecs par les deux
symphonies c'est à dire il faut que tout
le monde travaille ensemble vivent
ensemble fasse de la musique ensemble
donc surtout pas de couac et s'est
organisée par la voix du chef chef
d'orchestre chef de l'annuel ce je ne
sais pas mais il y avait une sorte
d'autorité comme ça on sait bien que
jean luc mélenchon a quelque chose de
ceux de ce chef presque autoritaire par
moments qui veut organiser la vie voilà
mais pour finir je dirais qu'il y avait
peut être aussi quelque chose d'un petit
peu plus glamour ah oui nous verrons
bien dimanche prochain je vais faire
l'hypothèse parce que dans le monde grec
justement harmonie c'était le nom d'une
déesse très belle très jeune femme qui
était la fille de mars et de venus donc
elle était très intéressante et par
rapport à notre vie politique c'est
intéressant aussi parce qu'elle
accordait des choses qui vont d'habitude
pas ensemble la guerre et l'amour la
concorde et l'adisq donc c'est grave
peut-être que c'est ça que jean luc
mélenchon avait aussi un qu'il était
peut-être plus habiter en terme de
gravité qui est un comme on a pu
l'interpréter rats dimanche qu'on sent
bien merci beaucoup mariette alors on
termine avec votre chronique vincent ce
soir on nous parlait de ces charters de
la honte de bodo boris johnson buju
airways aux éditions est fallu d'un rien
sans la requête introduite in extremis
par un migrant irakien auprès de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme et bien
le charter affrété à prix d'or par les
fautes et mécanique aurait décollé mardi
soir d'un aérodrome militaire direction
kigali capitale du rwanda à 6000 km de
là et ce en vertu enfin si j'ose dire du
partenariat scellé à la mi avril par le
pays des mille collines et la perfide
albion résolu à tarir le flux des airs
en prêt à s'entasser sur des
embarcations de fortune pour traverser
le channel à bord de l'avion ainsi
cloués au sol une poignée de clandestins
aux demandeurs d'asile bien loin du
contingent des 130 exfiltré initialement
prévu je veux dire que d'appel en
recours leur effectif a fondu restait
donc sept passagers trois iraniens deux
irakiens un albanais et un vietnamien à
vrai dire un hélico aurait suffi faux
départ donc pour le pont aérien dont
rêve au diable le bilan carbone boris
johnson et sa ministre de l'intérieur
l'ultra-conservatrice priti patel break
6 2 frénétique et groupies number one du
fantasque locataire du 10 downing street
laquelle patel a eu au moins l'honnêteté
de reconnaître que sous sa férule jamais
ses parents originaires de l'état du
gujarat dans l'ouest de l'inde n'aurait
pu s'établir sur les rives de la tamise
alors ce mécanisme est ce qu'il fait
consensus de l'autre côté de la manche
non pas vraiment quoique plébiscité par
les députés tories ce bien sûr qu'ils
vouent aux gémonies la cour de
strasbourg vient ce dispostif
d'expulsions forcées presque aussi
baroque qu'un chapeau de sa gracieuse
majesté aura déclenché un déluge de
griefs le haut commissariat pour les
réfugiés de l'onu amnesty international
le dénonce l'église anglicane le juge
immorales quant au prince charles plus
que jamais héritier de la couronne il
l'aurait qualifié en privé
d'épouvantables honni soit qui mal y
pense la lune et la planète mars on y
revient on va encore habitable et les
malouines sorry des falkland un peu trop
inhospitalières et bien beau jeu le
clown a jeté son dévolu sur le rwanda
gratifié pour services rendus de 140
millions d'euros l'ennui c'est que le
très austère paul kagame seul maître à
bord depuis près de 30 ans bayonne et en
bastille ses opposants quand il n'envoie
pas des commando de tueurs liquider au
kenya en afrique du sud l'ex compagnon
d'armes en rupture de banc mais voilà
tétanisés par la culpabilité qu'il
traîne depuis le génocide de 94
l'occident ménage cet autocrate timonier
d'une résurrection régenter à la
cravache
ça veut dire qu'il va renoncer bodjona
l'impression qu'au londres n'a pas
l'intention au nom il l'a dit d'ailleurs
le couac initial ne le décourage
nullement son équipe planchent déjà sur
les transferts à venir contesté jusque
dans les rangs de son parti on le sait
lui doit à tout prix arracher une
victoire fut sur le front migratoires
après le break six jurés si vous allez
voir ce que vous allez voir ce dont est
capable un royaume uni enfin affranchi
des diktats de bruxelles eh bien on a vu
le bilan en la matière et désastres haut
depuis janvier 10 mille clan des antes
accoster sur les côtes anglaises dont
444 pour la seule journée d'avant-hier
il en faudra d'autres charters pour
escamoter une telle cohorte
ne parviennent pas à ses fins on verra
on verra ce que ça donne merci beaucoup
merci vincent jeu merci mariette vous
regardez la soirée électorale et vous
n'y revenez avec beaucoup de mots à
décrypter on sera toutes les deux 19h36
ray wise as je serai dans l'essonne pour
suivre le match entre la ministre
ameline montchanin et l'ancien député
socialiste jérôme guedj dès 9h30 sur lcp
grande soirée électorale avec brigitte
boucher l'ensemble de la chaîne
parlementaire et sur le pont bien
évidemment pour vous faire vivre ce
second tour des législatives en
attendant votre soirée documentaire avec
un film ce soir sur le scandale de
l'amiante dans la série des mensonges de
l'histoire avec jean pierre gratien
demain clément mairie comme annette je
travaille et il a très vite
[Musique]